My name's Conor.
I'm an audiologist,
and I'm an expert in ears.
And today I'm going to show you
some earwax-removal videos.
There is liquidy, soupy earwax;
hard, brick-like earwax;
and a particular fungus
called Aspergillus niger.
Earwax is roughly half skin;
a little bit of sebum,
which is a fatty, oily substance;
and something very special
called ceruminous secretion.
And ceruminous glands secrete
this kind of sweaty liquid,
but it's got special molecules in it
which fight bacteria and
try and keep your ears safe.
You only ever need to remove your earwax
if it's bothering you.
So if you have hearing loss
or your ear is feeling
full or uncomfortable
or you feel like there's an
obvious blockage or pressure.
That is abnormal,
and you should go and see your doctor
or audiologist or practice nurse.
So, this is something I would describe
as sort of the soupy,
kind of quagmire-type wax.
So you can see actually
that the debris has a texture to it,
like a wavy texture and wavy lines in it.
So that means that it's
basically dead skin
that's emulsified,
and it's been treated
essentially with fizzy drops.
So sodium bicarb ear drops probably.
And what that does is it
makes the debris liquefy
and then slide further down the ear canal
and then against the drum.
And that really does cause
quite a significant hearing loss
and feeling of discomfort.
And what's happened here is that
it's kind of lost a little
bit of its structure,
which is quite difficult to deal with,
because usually this type of earwax
is quite resistant to suction.
The machine I'm using is
called a Guardian Projet.
Basically, you have a tank.
Is that hurting?
And you have to fill that tank with water,
which should be body temperature,
about 37 degrees Celsius.
And if it's too hot or too cold,
then it will induce a caloric effect,
which is where basically you're heating
or cooling the fluid
inside your inner ear,
and that causes unpleasant vertigo,
which is like a spinning dizziness,
like you're drunk.
So you put the instrument
in the ear canal,
and you aim the water at
the roof of the ear canal.
So never straight down the ear.
Never aim it at the eardrum.
That's really when accidents happen,
potentially perforation of the eardrum.
So you aim it at the
roof of the ear canal,
and you sort of move it
like a window washer.
And what that does is it creates
these vortices in the water
and a gentle swelling effect.
It goes into the ear
and then just flushes straight
back out into the cup.
So it's on the lowest setting,
and it's just squirting into the ear.
And we leave it there and
let the water do the work.
Most people find it quite pleasant.
There's a little bit of debris or slime
left on the eardrum.
In that situation, we'd
probably go in with suction
or maybe continue the irrigation
for a little bit longer
if the patient can tolerate it.
You'll definitely want to have
some earwax left in there.
Certainly not up against the drum
or anywhere near the eardrum.
So a nice smearing or slick of wax
around the ear canal
will leave the patient
protected against the ear drying out,
protected against infection, itching,
and obviously protection
against foreign bodies as well.
So that's a pretty nice-looking
eardrum right there.
When I first saw it, I thought,
oh, this will be an easy job,
because the wax is right there.
You can see it with your naked eye,
so it's all good.
But then as soon as I
tapped on it with the probe,
I thought, right, we're
in for a heavy ride here.
The only way I can describe it
is sort of really like a brick.
It was extremely tough.
And I started with the suction,
but that was, for all intents
and purposes, pointless.
So in this particular case,
I used something called
a Cawthorne hook No. 6.
And it's basically a
very, very, very small
metal right angle, essentially.
The end is perhaps a little pointy,
but it's not needle-sharp.
This was extremely impacted.
The reason it's dark,
much darker than the previous case,
is because it's old.
The older the wax is, the darker it is,
and that's because it oxidizes.
I try to be very, very gentle.
The Cawthorne hook is small enough
such that you can get
hook around the debris
and disturb it and leverage it out.
So really, to put it bluntly,
digging it out with a metal instrument
was the only way, really.
You tend to find with this very hard
impacted brick-like wax,
that you can have pain as well.
When the patient tries to self-treat
with water-based drops,
the plug will actually
expand a little bit,
so it'll absorb some of those drops
and then increase in size temporarily.
And if the plug is very
deep in the ear canal,
that can really, really hurt
and cause a tremendous ache.
The thing is, you always
have to go in stages,
because if you shove the hook in
and then pull just in one go,
you can cause barotrauma,
which is basically damage via pressure,
and that is excruciatingly painful.
So you really have to
go very, very carefully
and tread lightly.
What we can see here is
the sort of yellow frills
that are coming off the main plug.
That's just dead skin.
When we see an impacted plug like this,
there's usually sheets and sheets
of dead skin enveloping it,
sort of like lasagna, basically.
And then the darker brown bit,
that's very, very dense,
dry hard earwax,
which is just formed over
a long period of time.
It's impossible to say how old it is,
but, yeah, it's definitely
been in there a while.
The scientific name for it,
the particular fungus is
called Aspergillus niger.
The casual name for it is black mold.
Aspergillus niger lives everywhere.
It wouldn't a be shock for me
if there was some on your hand right now
or on your desk. It's very common.
So the likelihood is it was
either in the ear already
or it was on a fingernail
or under a fingernail
and the patient scratched their ear.
The reason it's got out of
control is anyone's guess.
So for this I'm using a suction probe
to get the debris out of the ear.
And really what I wanted to do
is remove the bed of the
fungus, the mycelium.
And that's why you'll see
this white clothy material
with the sort of goo underneath it.
That's the very thick, well-developed
rooty part of the fungus on the eardrum,
which is risky to some degree
because that's the kind of situation
where you can see a perforation.
And usually what we tend to find
is that patients who have these
very well-developed fungal infections
is more often than not
because they've used a lot
of antibiotic eardrops.
The reason why it's bad
to use antibiotic eardrops
when you don't need it
is because you are disrupting
the natural balance
of microorganisms in your ear.
And if you kill off all the good bacteria,
then the fungus is going,
"Hey, this is a party,"
and grow unchallenged.
I couldn't get all of the mycelium out
because it was sort of around the bend
and it was in a very,
very awkward position.
But I achieved most of what I wanted to,
which was to expose a
nice healthy eardrum.
And then of course that paved the way
for the antifungal drops to do their job.
This advice cannot be said enough.
If your ear isn't bothering you,
don't poke it, don't prod it,
don't treat it with anything,
don't put anything in it,
and just leave it be.
Most people will maybe
have an earwax blockage
maybe once or twice or
three times in their lives,
but it's not something
that you need to keep on top of regularly,
because your ears are self-cleaning
and they will usually
take care of themselves.